hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to maximum override now this
game has a little bit of backstory
apparently a giant meteor smashed into
Alabama and now everything gone to kaput
and we're gonna play g-man elimination
which involves killing all the men in
black which sounds really bad but I
don't know I kind of liked him even
though they probably want to domineer
all the aliens and I had to restart this
game because I originally started
playing it before but it is heavily
physically demanding and you're gonna
see why right about now right about now
oh hello hi I just wanted to give you a
little hug Oh God
I didn't mean to do a barrel roll
through your building oh lordy Lou I
don't know what that meter is on the
bottom I'm assuming that's my health or
maybe the health in the entire city
which admittedly is not doing very well
oh god camera stop doing that
flip oh okay so Baio haha so sorry oh
god dammit I didn't mean to get my
propeller blades oh excuse me I'm not
doing this on four I'm legit and I'm
legitimately trying here can I thank you
and away we go doing well I had to
restart the game because it's very
physically demanding and in this mode
all the little red god damnit I'm sorry
I'm sorry everybody
really I'm a friendly alien you know I
mean well but it's not going well for me
what is this rocket car that doesn't
well that's a lot of controls oh hello
oh [ __ ] that blew it up already
hello you want to be my friend Wow why
did you clip through your car and a beer
in a pile of blood
how about boosts ah lordy Oh God
oh it's it's a it's it's got that car
soccer game why can't I remember writing
a rocket League of course rocket car
League Oh God ah oh my god
Wow holy crap okay so this one oh I
didn't even do that
blame that one on me okay so this one if
I recall correctly is literally just a
wrecking ball and I came in like a me
and I just destroyed everything pasta
can I get those two guys besides me oh
sorry cop sorry I just wanted to gently
nudge you not actually doing the
official damage come on
they're right there I blowed it blue
everywhere
I'm gonna getcha maybe if I can get over
all the damage that's been done to my
wealth nope apparently not
oh-ho cop do you ha no oh oh he was just
looking in to see if there was something
wrong
ha ha ha the helmet I'm a fireman Oh
ha ha ha take this take my sugary
destruction you're gonna die eventually
from diabetes and then you'll learn what
just a few more in your dunzo oh no I'm
oh it's at a time but I'm never out of
soda god damn it ah ah I didn't do it
shockingly I only got three of them
my name is uh my name is uh cuz that's
all I do
let's try that again shall we just one
more time because I'm sure I can do it
without embarrassing myself plus the
hair to power ok
Oh what is this let's say world's please
please oh yes oh yes how am i steering
this do I even want to know do I even
understand the physics of everything
that's happening in this weird world
after this alien invaded you know I'm
not I'm pretty sure that this was this
world was asking for it
oh my god oh no are they still alive I
ran over him was a Peace Club I did his
best I could
oh I've got something stuck to me that
looks bloody and not happy Oh
hello oh my god it's too cool and the
music is so happy-go-lucky
who'da thunk tit hey there we go I think
I blew up the gas station but I'm not
100% certain on that one damn it Teddy's
almost there
sorry lady Oh God there I go jump jump
oh oh hello oh oh oh oh oh oh hello hang
on wait come back ah hello yes now I god
damn it come on why am I not correct
come on hang on a Gandhi if the camera
could stop flipping around randomly
there we go there's a target down how
about you
nope I'll miss okay I didn't want to hit
any of them actually and now where'd you
go you can't hide under the bridge for
me but apparently I can get stuck in a
goddamn building and then have the
camera flip-floppy everywhere except for
where I want to go where did you go
where oh where there you are got two of
them okay this is devastatingly
effective now oh holy crap
alrighty then I guess they didn't expect
a giant truck to be bashing through
buildings to get them I see you my
blood-red vision cease from all Angus
Cuse me alright yeah let's try that one
again
my blood-red vision cease from all
angles [ __ ] my blood red Rouge cease
from all angles I'll go around oh my me
I'll go around see ah I did a rod oh I
thought I'd get you with my whip tail
come here you can't run away poor guy
ah [ __ ] come on move it we got 10
seconds left god damn it
oh titty sprinkles no death and another
oh there was an oil in that burger what
do isn't attacking the other ones hell
yeah hello a Shuster
oh yes I can just stay right here
excuse me sorry I needed to commandeer
this stop shooting me please
there we go hey you you shouldn't have
been on the other side of that wall cuz
it's gone now
well nevermind it's gone now now look
don't mind that stay calm citizen dammit
you're remarkably resilient and maybe
you've been through war before but man
you are not Wow you have nerves of steel
dude you have just the constitution of
oh my god why are you not dead do you
deserve to live is this how this works
oh come on ah what [ __ ] the [ __ ] you
son of it oh you know it I somehow
accidentally killed someone else and I
can't intentionally kill that guy I'm
saving it for last if I can even get to
last excuse me
sorry okay apparently that's not gonna
destroy it Ramius straight into a
building hey I just wanted to talk with
you come into my office in this building
please any minute now there we go that
looks like an attack helicopter we say
yes yes yes yes yes this is not easy to
control oh my god is worse than the last
one
oh lordy huh I didn't mean it sorry okay
maybe I did mean it because one went
down oh goodness gracious this is
impossible I'm not doing this on purpose
ah son of a [ __ ] I can't move flip
there we go
good god they need to fix that I mean
maybe I need to need to get better but
I'm gonna blame other people while still
can just whoa whoa wait whoa whoa whoa
whoa okay I'm just gonna fire wildly
hope for the best
I can't even turn what the [ __ ] is
happening oh my god you got to be
kidding me this is a bunch of malarkey
it doesn't even turn the way that it
says it's turning I'm shooting missiles
at you just blow up Oh God
oh it's deliberating come on
just blow one of them up whatever what's
the point of an attack helicopter if I
can't give one of them Oh baloney
yeah Oh Frank it just launched me off of
that rock in this direction what the
hell oh my god oh it's so bad it's so
bad
Wow is that round got to me
that one got to me a little bit I will
admit I could have handled that better
hello sir
sorry what the what yeah that's right
snipe your eye err [ __ ] Oh what about
you bonk gun with your head how about a
little bit of you hiding behind this
wall I see too bad for you I know the
secret of no clipping hey want to get a
mouthful of bullet sorry you got a
mouthful of tank treads instead it's all
I had in reserve thank you gonna kill
you with you blow you whoa you're going
fast
you're just zooming it right into your
death I don't mind saves me the time hey
where do you think you're going away got
you bad someone hiding up in the
building here well not anymore never
mind
I was rather quick sorry about that I
was hoping they'll last longer that's
what she said
someone's hiding out in the firehouse
too bad alright so there's got to be
someone yeah over here they seem to be
all in a bunch but I'm about to blow up
no
oh just right here he's gonna Oh got you
are you gonna run nowhere okay - g-man
remaining a minute 30 I got plenty of
time
it's gonna be great Bogg yes one more
almost there
got a plow I'm gonna finish you off with
a four-door sedan how do you feel but
yeah it finish the game before I was
even done I sure do love this fanfare
music of death
good old buh buh buh bit better there
better bands gonna win better flyer
alright I did it I did I finally did it
I understood how to play the game by
taking my head out of my own ass and
then learning the mechanics of the game
and taking it a bit more patiently but
those attack helicopters oh boy they
need some work but that is maximum
override there's a lot more to this game
I imagine so you can find it on Steam
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought of the game
the comments below and as always I will
see you in the next video bye
about here extinct you my body